[Music]
hey jake can i get a large bottle of
that buys you
you know what make it too large
how can you drink like that i used to
complain that every day felt the same
and now every day is the same hey jake i
have died 144 times
and every day ends like this but it
doesn't matter
not when you've lost everything you've
loved
renter man who's had me killed 150 times
the power to rewrite history
is mine heads up i know everything
that's gonna happen
one thing that never changes what's up
pretty boy
bunch of [ __ ] are killing me for
reasons that remain a mystery
i am guanyin and guanyin had done this
iron cry
[Music]
it's for you roy can you hear me we
can't explain it right now but i'm gonna
need your help gemma
the only woman i've ever loved and who
can stop this is still alive
i have to get killed hi roy over and
over again
until i save her you need to learn how
to fight with a sword
i would only have a day i think we get a
lot done in a day
[Music]
someone's been the busiest little beaver
i'm starting the death loop because of
you exactly
bring them all
i can do this all day
[Music]
[Music]
you